[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
US-Präsident Joe Biden hat sich
vorsichtig optimistisch geäußert dass
man eine Lösung finden werde für die von
der Hamas verschlept Geiseln man arbeite
permanent daran hieß es aus dem Weißen
Haus und sei einer Einigung näher als je
zuuvor das weckt Hoffnungen bei den
Angehörigen deren Verzweiflung und Wut
täglich wächst Wut auch auf die
israelische Regierung Benjamin netanahu
steht auch innenpitisch gewaltig unter
Druck Dominik lesmeister berichtet aus
Tel
Aviv sie sind gekommen um mit Benjamin
netanahu zu sprechen die Angehörigen der
Geiseln wollen von Israels
Ministerpräsidenten heute abend wissen
ob sich was tut ob es eine Bewegung gibt
in der
geiselfrage wir haben Fragen und
verdienen Antworten auf
diese bringt sie nach Hause jetzt rufen
Sie am Weltkindertag vor der Vertretung
der uniceef in Tel Aviv die Angehörigen
von 40 Kindern und Jugendlichen die von
der Hamas entführt wurden auch Joni as
bankt um seine Familie seine zwei
kleinen Töchter seine Frau und seine
Schwiegermutter alle samt auch deutsche
Staatsbürger sind Geiseln der
Hamas mein eigenes wohlbfinden ist mir
Moment nicht wichtig ich will nur meine
Familie zurück ich würde dafür mein
Leben
geben die Familien der Geiseln kämpfen
an mehreren Fronten gerade jetzt will
eine rechtsextreme Regierungspartei ein
Gesetz voranbringen D die Todesstrafe
für Terroristen erleichtern soll gerade
jetzt können das die
nicht
gebrauchen wenn das diese Psychopathen
verwenden um den Geiseln Schaden
zuzufügen dann ist deren Blut an deinen
Händen Kinder Familien sie leiden auf
beiden Seiten diese Frühgeborenen Babys
waren bis vor kurzem noch im umkämpften
alschifer Krankenhaus in gasastadt nun
werden sie nach Ägypten in Sicherheit
gebracht wir mussten das Kind im
Brutkasten zurücklassen als wir in den
Süden flüchteten wir dachten Baby ist
dort in Sicherheit dass das Krankenhaus
angegriffen würde kam für uns als Schock
doch Krankenhäuser sind in diesem Krieg
keine sicheren Orte israelsarmee
veröffentlicht Aufnahmen die beweisen
sollen dass mehrere der Geiseln
zeitweise in das alschifer Krankenhaus
in Gazastreifen gebracht worden waren
Hamas hat unsere Geiseln ins
schiferhospital verschleppt und ermordet
Hamas hat terrortunnel unter dem
Krankenhaus
errichtet israelische tren Rücken
derweil weiter in Gasa Stadt vor dabei
soll es nach palästinensischen Angaben
auch zum Beschuss einer von Indonesien
finanzierten Klinik mit 12 Toten
gekommen sein unabhängig überprüfen
lassen sich die Zahlen
nicht Sirenenalarm am Abend auch wieder
in Tel Aviv Raketenabwehr über der Stadt
Menschen bringen sich in Bunkern in
Sicherheit wenig Anzeichen für eine
Feuerpause auf beiden
Seiten dann schalten wir noch zu unsem
krespondenten Michael beberunge in Tel
Aviv Michael es gab ja Vermutung dass es
sogar heute Abend schon eine längere
Kampfpause geben könnte was hatte es
denn mit den Berichten darüber auf
sich ja wenn sogar der amerikanische
Präsident sich in vorausallenem
Optimismus äußert dann sollte man denken
dass sich auch die israelische Regierung
anschließt aber das ist wie schon so oft
in sem Krieg nicht so im Gegenteil
skeptische Töne aus der Regierung wie
wir in den Beitrag gesehen haben da tobt
ein Streit zwischen den hartlin und den
kompromissbereiten und das könnte sich
natürlich auch auf die geiselverhandlung
auswirken was jetzt letztendlich der
Knackpunkt ist an den vielen Details die
bisher veröffentlicht wurden das ist
schwer zu sagen ich denke dass
sicherlich eine große Rolle die Länge
der Waffenpause spielen wird 5 Tage sind
im Gespräch das ist sehr viel Zeit für
die Hamas sich zu reorganisieren das
sehen viele in der Regierung skeptisch
also bei allem ismus der im Moment
verbreitet wird und ich denke auch es
wird diesen geiseldeal irgendwann geben
noch gibt es keine Aussicht dass er
tatsächlich vollzogen wird Israels
Verteidigungsminister außerdem eine
Ausweitung des Krieges in den Süden des
Gazastreifens angekündigt wie passt das
denn dazu dass man ja die
Zivilbevölkerung aufforderte sich in
eben diesem Süden in Sicherheit zu
bringen also zunächst mal ich glaube
niem wollte an der Entschlossenheit der
Regierung zweifeln diesen Kampf gegen
die Hamas auch im Süden zu Ende zu
bringen Moment ist man noch im Norden
wohl sehr erfolgreich aber dort so nach
jüngsten Angaben ist vielleicht nur ein
Drittel der hamaskämpfer von etwa 30.000
die Zahl wird genannt wenn der Rest im
Süden ist dann wird das ein noch mal
deutlich schwieriger Kampf denn aus
Sicht der Hamas ist das der Endkampf es
gibt keinen kommen sondern nur ergeben
und das bei etwa 2 Millionen Menschen
die sich inzwischen da unten aushalten
wie das gehen soll wo die sich
hinbegeben sollen das bleibt bis jetzt
das Geheimnis der israelischen Regierung
bis jetzt sind ja auch keine vorher
Vorkehrungen Vorkehrungen getroffen
worden wo diese Menschen hingehen sollen
ein großes Zeltlager und der Art ist in
dieser Größen Ordnung jedenfalls nicht
abzusehen also wie dieser Kampf dann
aussehen wird das mag sich bisher noch
keiner vorstellen ja danke Michael nach
Tel
Aviv das dass den ostkonflikt auch
jenseits des aktuellen Krieges weltweit
polarisiert viel mehr als andere
Konflikte und Kriege das ist nicht neu
aber die Wucht mit der das in den
letzten Wochen sichtbar wurde hat dann
doch viele überrascht dazu gehört auch
dass dabei ein Ausmaß an Antisemitismus
und auch antiwestlichen Ressentiments
freigelegt wurde über dass man in der
Vergangenheit vielleicht lieber
hinwegsah und vielleicht auch gar nicht
so genau wissen wollte was in einigen
Moscheen hier Lande gepredigt wird oder
wie viel Einfluss die türkische
Regierung darauf hat der türkisch
islamischen ditipp dem größten
moscheeverband kommt dabei besondere
Bedeutung zu zumal gerade erst der
Auftritt eines Taliban in Köln für
Aufregung sorgt kameran safiarian
berichtet die ditipmosche in Köln
Korweiler hier tritt vor wenigen Tagen
abdulbi om auf ein hochrangiger Taliban
der Leiter der afghanischen Lebensmittel
und neibehörde soll zuvor an einer who
Konferenz in den Niederlanden
teilgenommen haben wie kann ein
Vertreter dieses Regimes öffentlich in
Deutschland auftreten die
bundesinnenministerin sucht Antworten er
hatte ja ein gültiges Schengenvisum aus
einem Nachbarstaat die jetzt überprüfen
wie das möglich war ich glaube das ist
auch wichtig dass wir dort Aufklärung
bekommen weil ansonsten kann es ja
unseren Behörden nicht auffallen wenn
dort gültige schengenvisa sind ich
erwarte auch von dietip Aufklärung
darüber wie das zustande kommen konnte
dass er diese keit nutzen durfte die
DITIB in Erklärungsnot der Verband zeigt
sich schockiert ein Kulturverein habe
eine als religiös angekündigte
Veranstaltung organisiert und dabei
Vertragsbruch begangen in einer
Pressemitteilung heißt es die DTI blind
jede auch nur geistige Nähe zur Taliban
oder anderen Extremisten ab bei dem
Auftritt sein bisher keine
strafrechtlich relevanten Äußerung
gefallen so NRW in Minister re heute
nach einem Treffen mit der ditip solange
die Bundesregierung der Bundesanwalt die
Taliban nicht klar als
Terrororganisation festschreiben und mit
einem
Betätigungsverbot leen und alle
Mitglieder des Taliban Administration
auf diese sanktionssetzen z.B der EU
setzen könnte ein solcher Auftritt bei
uns immer wieder passieren ist nicht zu
verhindern die dtip im Fokus der
islamverband untersteht der türkischen
Religionsbehörde dianet seit Wochen
hetzt ihr Leiter aus Ankara gegen Israel
Israel se doch im Herzen islamischen
Welt begehe in Gaza Völkermord so Ali
Erbas wie kommt das beim Muslimen in
Deutschland an beim Freitagsgebet der
ditip Moschee am Berliner cololumbiadamm
klingt das
so ab wie viel toten Zivilisten wird
Israel die Invasion stoppen und sagen
jetzt haben wir unser Ziel erreicht
diese Frage muss man sich stellen in der
meainz Mosche kommen die antisemitischen
Töne aus Ankara so an das stimmt auch so
wie er es gesagt hat das ist ein
vökörmer das kann man gar nicht
abstreiten ist auch ein kriegsverprechen
die Kölner Zentralmoschee der ditip mit
knapp 1000 Moscheegemeinden ist die
dietip der größte islamverband in
Deutschland ihre Imame sind türkische
Staatsbeamte aus Ankara importiert wird
dadurch auch Antisemitismus in deutschen
Moscheen verbreitet ja sagt ein Mitglied
der Deutschen
Islamkonferenz wir hatten ja in der
jüngsten Vergangenheit immer wieder
antisemitische Äußerungen von Imamen
auch innerhalb der tip also das ist ja
kein neues Thema Antisemitismus war
immer ein Thema ein muslimischer
Antisemitismus in auch in deutschen
Moscheen und leider hat bisher nie eine
wirklich tiefergehende
Auseinandersetzung mit dieser Form des
Antisemitismus stattgefunden wir
konfrontieren die dtip mit diesen
Vorwürfen ein Interview kommt nicht
zustande bis heute ist die dtip in
vielen Bundesländern Ansprechpartner für
die Politik cduchef März fordert
Konsequenzen wir müssen von diesen
Verbänden erwarten wenn sie
Gesprächspartner der Politik bleiben
wollen dass Sie sich ohne Wenn und Aber
zum Existenzrecht des Staates Israel
bekennen und dass sie ohne Wenn und Aber
die Religionsfreiheit in unserem Lande
akzeptieren die ditip wirkt bisher beim
islamischen Religionsunterricht in
Hessen im Saarland in Niedersachsen und
in nordrin-westfalen mit was wenn hier
Antisemitismus einfließt die
grünpolitikerin Lamia kador hat früher
selbst Islamunterricht gegeben wir
müssen darüber sprechen was mit dem
islamischen Religionsunterricht ist ob
jetzt weiß ich nicht Israel bezogen
Antisemitismus plötzlich sagbar ist das
darf er auf keinen Fall auch nicht im
Rahmen des islamischen
Religionsunterrichts werden und deshalb
würde ich meinen sollte auch die
Deutsche Islamkonferenz dieses Thema
sehr intensiv behandeln
nordranwestfalen hat jetzt angekündigt
seine Zusammenarbeit mit der dtip beim
islamischen Religionsunterricht zu
prüfen jetzt geht's erstmal mit
Nachrichten weiter Heinz zunächst mit
der Debatte über den Bundeshaushalt ja
nach dem Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts zum Haushalt
ist weiter offen wie die
Regierungskoalition die Finanzlücke
schließen will SPD und Grüne lehnten es
erneut ab dabei auf Einsparungen etwa im
Sozialbereich zu setzen unklar ist auch
noch wie groß die Finanzlücke am Ende
tatsächlich wird denn allein beim Klima
und transformationsfond könnte neben den
nun gestrichenen 60 Milliarden Euro auch
schon eine frühere Bereitstellung
betroffen sein 26 Milliarden aus 2020
und zudem Gelder des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds allein
dieses Jahr flossen daraus schon jetzt
mehr als 31
Milliarden auf dem afrikaagipfel im
Rahmen der G20 Initiative compact with
Africa hat sich Deutschland den Staaten
Afrikas als verlässlicher Partner
angeboten das Potenzial Afrikas sei
riesig z.B bei nachhaltiger
Energieversorgung so Bundeskanzler
Scholz der auch mehr Investitionen der
deutschen Wirtschaft erwartete so will
Berlin die euarika Initiative für grüne
Energie bis 2030 mit 4 Milliarden Euro
unterstützen an dem Gipfel beteiligten
sich 13 afrikanische Staaten mit dem
Ziel Investitionen in diese Länder zu
stärken die US-Regierung hat der Ukraine
ein neues rüstungspaket im Wert von 100
Millionen US-Dollar und erneut
langfristige Unterstützung zugesagt
Verteidigungsminister Austen Versicherte
Präsident Selens bei einem Besuch in
Kiev die Vereinigten Staaten würden
weiterhin an der Seite der Ukraine
stehen in deren Kampf für Freiheit gegen
der russischen Aggressoren heute und in
der Zukunft allerdings gibt es im
US-Kongress zunehmend Vorbehalte gegen
die Unterstützung der
Ukraine ein 18-Jähriger aus Hessen ist
in Untersuchungshaft wegen des Verdachts
eine schwere staatsgefährdende Gewalttat
vorbereitet zu haben laut
Staatsanwaltschaft und landeskriminal
hat er nach den bisherigen Ermittlungen
eine antisemitische sowie
rechtsextremistische Grundeinstellung er
habe in einschlägigen Foren mehrfach
gedroht für seine Ziele Menschen töten
zu
wollen in einem der größten
mafiaprozesse Italiens sind rund 200
Angeklagte verurteilt worden das Gerücht
im Süden des Landes verhängte
Haftstrafen von einigen Monaten bis zu
30 Jahren schuldig gesprochen wurden
neben Anführern und Mitglied der
kalabrischen Verbrecherorganisation
drangeta auch deren Helfer bei der
Polizei sowie in der Politik und
Verwaltung die Anklagepunkte reichten
von Drogenhandel bis hin zu Erpressung
und
Mordversuch bei Missbrauch unterm Dach
der Kirche lag der kritische Fokus
bislang ja eher auf der katholischen
Kirche zumal sich deren Bischöfe
sichtlich schwer damit tun persönliche
Verantwortung zu übernehmen so gesehen
ist es bemerkenswert in welcher
Geschwindigkeit jetzt die höchste
Repräsentantin der evangelischen Kirche
Annette kurschuss zurückgetreten ist
auch wenn der ratsvorsitzendinen der EKD
anzumerken ist dass Sie persönlich ist
ungerecht empfindet diese Konsequenz
ziehen zu müssen für die evangelische
Kirche ist das jedenfalls eine schwere
Erschütterung und sie wird wohl nicht
die letzte bleiben im Januar wird es ein
umfängliches Gutachten zum Ausmaß
sexualisierter Gewalt in der
evangelischen Kirche geben Dominik
Müller Russell über den Rücktritt und
seine
Hintergründe zur chefinnensache hatte
Annette kurschuss die Aufarbeitung der
Missbrauchsskandale in der evangelischen
Kirche erklärt heute stolpert sie über
genau solch einen Skandal nach einer
Woche immer heftigerer Vorwürfe
inzwischen hat sich die Lage derart
zugespitzt dass es für mich nur eine
Konsequenz gibt um Schaden von meiner
Kirche abzuwenden ich trete von beiden
kirchlichen leitungsämtern zurück in der
Sache bin ich mit mir im Reinen ich habe
zu jeder Zeit nach bestem Wissen und
Gewissen gehandelt zwei eidestattliche
Erklärungen stehen dem Gegenüber zwei
Männer haben der Siegener Zeitung
geschildert Annette kurschuss bereits in
den 90er Jahren zu ihrer Zeit als
Pfarrerin in Siegen auf
Missbrauchsvorwürfe gegen einen
Kirchenmitarbeiter hingewiesen zu haben
dieser Mitarbeiter habe seine Stellung
ausgenutzt um Jugendliche und junge
Männer zu sexuellen zu dräen kurschuss
war mit diesem Mitarbeiter befreundet
bis zuletzt gab sie dagegen an sich zwar
an ein Gespräch über den Mitarbeiter zu
erinnern von den Missbrauchsvorwürfen
aber erst dieses Jahr erfahren zu haben
der Leiter der Lokalredaktion der
siegender Zeitung steht im engen
Austausch mit den Menschen die die
Vorwürfe gegen kurschuss erheben es gibt
Reaktionen von Seiten der Betroffenen
aber man darf sich jetzt nicht
vorstellen dass da irgendwo Freude
Erleichterung oder sonst was vorherrscht
sondern man sollte Respekt für diese
Entscheidung für eine konsequente
Entscheidung wie glaubwürdig kann jemand
aufklären der selbst beschuldigt wird
vertuscht zu haben auch Betroffene von
sexualisierter Gewalt im
beteiligungsforum der evangelischen
Kirche hatten auf den Rücktritt gedrängt
im sinine der Betroffenen ist der
Schritt wichtig und richtig den Frau Dr
kchuss gegangen ist und jetzt geht's
darum dass wir wieder weiter ohne
Störungen im beteiligungsforum
sexualisierte Gewalt äh arbeiten können
das verspricht die neue kommissarische
Ratsvorsitzende die Hamburger Bischöfin
Kirsten fers am Nachmittag der Rücktritt
sei ja gerade ein Zeichen dass die
evangelische Kirche Missbrauchsvorwürfe
ehrlich aufarbeiten wolle konsequent
klar und zwar auch völlig selbstkritisch
das ist das was ich glaube dass durch
ihren Rücktritt da noch mal neu einen
Blick drauf gesetzt wurde doch es gibt
heute auch weitaus weniger optimistische
Einschätzungen wozu die evangelische
Kirche überhaupt in der Lage sei es ist
in meinen Augen schon bezeichnend dass
es wieder einen Fall brauchte wo
Betroffene sich an die Presse wenden
dann eine Öffentlichkeit hergestellt
wird um dann Aufklärung Aufdeckung und
Transparenz zu erreichen und dass in
einer solchen Konstellation dann eine
kirchenverantwortliche aufgrund des
öffentlichen Drucks sagt sie muss jetzt
gehen mir ist es wichtig dass wir
verbindliche Standards für solche
Aufdeckung und Aufklärung haben auch und
gerade für die betroffene und an diesen
Strukturen fehlt das im Moment der
evangelischen Kirche fast 20 Millionen
Protestanten Leben in Deutschland nun
wird es darum gehen wieder Vertrauen
herzustellen argentinien hat einen neuen
Präsidenten der nicht nur wegen seiner
auffälligen Frisur mit Donald Trump
verglichen wird sondern auch wegen
seiner populistischen halsversprechen
und dem Personenkult den seine Anhänger
pflegen mitab milai wird nun ein
Politiker die zweit größte
Volkswirtschaft Südamerikas regieren der
sich selbst als
anarchokapitalist bezeichnet früher
nannte man das
Turbokapitalismus heute heißt es eher
wirtschaftslibertär der Grundgedanke ist
der gleiche jeder sei seines Glückes
Schmied und der Staat soll sich
raushalten für Argentiniens Linke
peronisten ist der Wahlausgang natürlich
an Desaster oder wie ihre berühmte
Präsidentengattin Evita Peron einst sang
don't cry for me
er
berichtet am Morgen danach kennen die
Zeitungen in Buenos Aires nur eine
Geschichte den zumindest in dieser
Deutlichkeit unerwarteten Sieg von
Javier m für den Wahlverlierer Sergio
Massa ist erst weiter hinten in den
blätternplatz und vor dem Kiosk treffen
wir die die gestern nicht feiern waren
und trotzdem in Katerstimmung
sind schlecht schlecht ein Schwachkopf
wie der dürfte niemals Präsident werden
wer wählt denn so einen
sie alle hier z.B in der Nacht erlebt
buenes Aires einen Jubel wie seit dem
WM-Sieg nicht mehr einen radikalen
politischen Neuanfang verspricht
Wahlsieger jaavier m als er gemeinsam
mit seiner Schwester seiner engsten
Vertrauten auf die Bühne
tritt von heute an ist Schluss mit dem
Staat der allmächtig ist der Armut
produziert und von dem nur wenige
profitieren während die Mehrheit der
argentinia leidet ab heute ist Schluss
damit dass die Politiker und ihre
Freunde sich das Land aufteilen
unsichtbar neben ihm stehen die
eigentlichen Wahlgewinner Wut und
Frustration von Millionen Argentinier
seit Jahren leiden sie unter wachsender
Inflation und Armut die Wahl m ist
Ausdruck eines vollständigen
Vertrauensverlustes in die etablierte
Politik wir brauchen einen Wandel so wie
bisher kann es unmöglich weitergehen wir
haben ernsthaft ans auswandn gedacht ich
habe ihm meine Stimme gegeben weil ich
will dass mein Sohn eine Zukunft hat ich
glaube an sie sagen er ist verrückt aber
mir ist ein Verrückter lieber als jemand
der uns weiter
beklaut m will die Zentralbank
abschaffen die Zentralbank klaut unser
Geld die Kettensäge ist das
Markenzeichen des studierten Ökonom
brachial wie seine Auftritte und das
Versprechen alles Bisherige zu Kleinholz
zu verarbeiten mehr als die Hälfte der
Ministerien will er abschaffen und wie
er mit der Zentralbank umgehen will
zeigt er in diesem Wahlkampf
auf ähnliche Art und Weise will er sich
weite Teile des Sozialstaats vorknüpfen
und parallel den Dollar als Währung
einführen denen die ihn nicht gewählt
haben macht das
Angst ich weiß nicht was mit unserem
Land passieren wird aber wenn m tut was
er angekündigt hat wird das ein
Disaster doch manche Beobachter wiegeln
ab m ging es nur um Aufmerksamkeit alles
halb so
wild das istine wahlkampfrorik und
Strategie utung es sind Werkzeuge die
funktionieren um Stimmen zu gewinnen
aber im Kern ist mele schlicht ein
konservativer ein konservativer der als
Quereinsteiger in die Politik kaum
vernetzt ist aber dringend Verbündete in
den Institutionen und Parlamenten
gewinnen muss um seine Wahlversprechen
umzusetzen gelingt ihm das nicht könnten
sich die von ihm beschworenen
Kettensägen in den Köpfen eines Tages
gegen ihn
richten und mit demck auf die deutsche
Wirtschaft geht's jetzt bei dir weiter
an der Börse ist der lendex DAX mit
einem leichten Verlust in die Woche
gestartet besondere Aufmerksamkeit galt
heute der bayeraktie Frank betmann um
welche Neuigkeiten ging es dabei ja um
schlechte um sehr schlechte sogar das
Bayer Ärger mit Glyphosat hat ist nicht
neu umstritten ob der Unkraut Vernich
der krebserregend ist am Wochenende
verlor man den vierten Prozess infolge
heute aber schlug noch etwas anderes ins
Kontor nämlich der überraschende Abbruch
einer weit fortgeschrittenen Studie und
zwar nicht für irgendein Mittel sondern
für ein Medikament gegen Thrombose und
Vorhof fllimmern eines das als Perle in
Bayers Pharma Pipeline galt der Flop
erweist sich als Schock die bayeraktie
stürzt ab gleich um 18 % einer der
stärksten Kursstürze in der
konzngeschichte der Pharmariese ganz
offensichtlich angeschlagen bei
Glyphosat belasten milliard schwere
rechtsrisiken und jetzt floppt auch noch
einer der größten wenn nicht der größte
Hoffnungsträger und was bedeutet das wie
wird die Situation eingeschätzt ja
selten waren die Sorgen größer bayer hat
hohe Schulden ist also auf
Forschungserfolge angewiesen da tut so
eine geplatzte Hoffnung heute besonders
weh Investoren und beschäftigte traf die
Nachricht heute unvorbereitet und so ist
zur Stunde auch völlig unklar wie es mit
dem Präparat weitergeht und im übrigen
auch was das für die Belegschaft
bedeutet weltweit beschäftigt Bayer über
100.000 Mitarbeiter davon knapp 23 000
in Deutschland Frank betmann vielen Dank
gerne in Jena findet heute und morgen
der 16 digitalgipfel der Bundesregierung
statt unter dem Schwerpunktthema
digitale Transformation in der
Zeitenwende nachhaltig resilient
zukunftsorientiert rund 1000 Vertreter
aus Politik und Wirtschaft beraten über
die Digitalisierung in den
verschiedensten Bereichen und auch über
den Einsatz von künstlicher
Intelligenz ausführlich dazu später im
heute schonal Update auch ein Interview
mit einem
ki-exerten nach der 2:3 Niederlage gegen
die Türkei steht für die deutsche
Fußballnationalmannschaft morgen das
nächste Testspiel an gegen Österreich zu
sehen live im ZDF ab 2015 Uhr zu den
Vorbereitungen von Bundestrainer
nagelsmann auf das Spiel Stefan Bier
drastische personelle Konsequenzen die
es sie nach Niederlagen schon mal gibt
sind nicht zu erwarten der Bundestrainer
richtet den Blick auf das
Abschlusstraining und hofft auf einen
guten
länderspieljahresabschluss gar nichts im
Abschlusstraining ich schaue nur zu weil
ich einfach sehen wie viel spricht der
Spieler was wie sehen seine Augen aus
was ist für ein Eindruck noch mal so
werden auf jeden Fall nicht komplett
andere Ordnung oder andere Dinge spielen
sondern nuanen anpassen neben der
Verhinderung von Gegentoren bietet sich
die Chancenverwertung für die Anpassung
von an ein Sieg zu null fehlt noch in
der kurzen erra nagelsmann als
Stimmungsaufheller nach der Türkei
Niederlage
daheim es gab ja Zeiten da war im
Fußball dann wenigstens auf die
frauenverlass das ist unbekanntlich auch
nicht mehr so auch die
Frauennationalmannschaft hatte ja ihr
wmdebakel und ein
trainerinnendrama Martina fost
Tecklenburg war danach regelrecht
abgetaucht es gab Verwerfungen mit dem
DFB Anfang des Monats wurde ihr Vertrag
vorzeitig aufgelöst nun hat sich die
ex-bundestrainerin im ZDF erstmals
öffentlich geäußert und das ziemlich
schonungslos schonungslos zu sich selbst
es ist jedenfalls eher selten dass
Menschen die öffentliche Spitzenposition
bekleideten so offen über ihr seelenhal
sprechen Volker Grube
berichtet dreieinhalb Monate nach dem
Vorrunden aus kann Martina V Tecklenburg
endlich sprechen über diesen Moment
ihrer größten Sport Niederlage und die
Zeit danach über depressive Zustände und
Panikattacken da sind Ängste da ist eine
Unsicherheit da ist eine Lehre in meinem
Kopf eine Aufarbeitung der WM in
Australien und Neuseeland mit allen
Beteiligten wurde unmöglich für Sie ich
war nicht in der Lage konstruktiv
vernünftig zu sprechen ich wer war nicht
in der Lage eine wm-analyse zu machen
ich war krank war gestresst war war
einfach
innerlich leer müde kaputt als ob dir
jemand den Stecker zieht ich habe 6 Kil
abgenommen habe vier Wochen hier gelegen
konnte nichts
machen keine Menschen sehen irgendwo
raus weil ich gar nicht in der Lage war
viel geweint Ende Oktober meldet sie
sich beim DFB als gesund nimmt ihren
Resturlaub und hält zwei öffentliche
Vorträge dafür bekommt sie viel Kritik
auch von ihren Spielerinnen die gehofft
hatten mit ihrer Trainerin das
Geschehene besprechen zu können im
Nachhinein muss ich sagen Fehler ja es
wäre besser gewesen zumindest bestimmte
Leute zu informieren ich habe den DFB
informiert dass dass das kommen kann und
dass es natürlich auch öffentlich werden
kann inzwischen hat Horst rubesch die
Verantwortung als interimsbundestrainer
übernommen Forst Tecklenburg will sich
nicht einmischen hält aber Kontakt zu
einzelnen Spielerinnen ich schätze Horst
ich weiß wie er wie er den Weg geht ich
habe wie gesagt auch mehrfach die
Botschaften gesendet ich wünsche euch
alles Gute ich bin mit Herzen bei dieser
Mannschaft noch mal ich war mit
Stolz Bundestrainerin ich ich habe alles
was ich geben konnte nach besten Wissen
und Gewissen reingegeben inzwischen geht
es ihr wieder gut Martina Voss
Tecklenburg und der DFB haben den
Vertrag aufgelöst doch mit Präsident
Bernt Neuendorf möchte sie unbedingt
noch einmal sprechen ich möchte nur auch
da die Chance haben
wähend Neuendorf ein paar Dinge von mir
wie es mir einfach auch ging und und was
mich auch berührt hat und das möchte ich
einfach auf der privaten Ebene mit ihm
im Gespräch auch noch mal erklären
können ihre Zukunft ob sie wieder als
Trainerin arbeiten will lässt sie
offen das ganze Interview mit Martina
FOS tcklenburg können Sie bei
ztfheute.de sehen und natürlich auch in
der ztf heute App
so viel von uns zum heute journal gleich
nach dem Wetter geht's mit dem
montagskino weiter und danach um
23:55 Uhr meldet sich Gund Gause mit
unserem heute joural Update auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
Wiedersehen guten Abend
Nachttemperaturen unter
-30° sind auch für den Norden
Skandinaviens eher ungewöhnlich morgen
liegen dort die Höchsttemperaturen um
-1° so kalt ist es bei uns in
Mitteleuropa natürlich nicht aber die
Strömung dreht doch jetzt häufiger mal
wieder auf nördliche Richtungen und dann
kommt Schnee doch zumindest mal fast in
Greif weiter wir sehen hier das Tief
Marco das morgen weiter nach Osten zieht
und es bringt doch ein bisschen
schneemit sie sehen das in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen und auch an den Alpen
erstmal aber bringt es Regen mit mit
heute Nacht in der Mitte und auch im
Süden Deutschlands die Regenfälle in
Norddeutschland lassen mehr und mehr
nach die Temperaturen sinken heute Nacht
auf 8 bis 2° und morgen bleibt es kühl
mit 6° z.B am Alpenrand in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen der ckermark und an der
Ostsee und 10° am Rhein das wird ein
recht trüber Dienstag mit Regenfällen
und dann später auch Schneefällen die
schneefägrenze sinkt im Laufe des Tages
auf 600 m in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen am Alpenrand liegt sie um
1000 m spätestens am Nachmittag kommt
hier im Nordwesten auch schon mal die
Sonne zum Vorschein bei einem Wind aus
nördlichen Richtungen am Mittwoch kann
es dann noch für einige Schneeschauer
hier im östlichen Bayern reichen sonst
gibt's nach Nebel häufig Sonnenschein
bevor dann es von Nordwesten schon
wieder regnerisch und milder wird der
Donnerstag wird stürmisch an der See und
milde der Freitag regnerisch und wie sie
jetzt hier am Trend für Dresden sehen
können werden die Nächte auf Mittwoch
und auf Donnerstag sehr frostig danach
geht es kälter weiter als zuletzt und
mit etwas Schnee guten Abend